this week we've got snake bite tampon
cocktail and safety refusal it's stupid
snake bite huh like the beer what's
what's what's the snake give it to me
do it a David Hume my sweater I'll [ __ ]
you this is a snake bite this Indian
burns or whatever is this actually hurts
[Music]
[Music]
real quick no friend if you're not going
to cry from it but it's shocking you
like adrenaline shade like this you like
this it's shocking right it hurts a lot
more than you think it would look sight
with me it feels really weird
you've been really embarrassing that's
just not have been super embarrassing
she if she got snake bit she just goes
what is David talking do it hear that
dude Hiromi oh no don't do it on the way
do it on okay moving on I want to know
what's the snake by thing about in
Oklahoma this man was going he's
visiting his friend's house and he got
attacked by a snake and a space oh [ __ ]
let me show you oh nice table is one of
my biggest [ __ ] fear that's such an
irrational fear really yeah snake on the
face no snake bite no no just snake
bites yeah poisonous snake bite this is
oh that's really good is good you're a
man of many useless talents that also
looks like a sideways vagina that also
means you don't have any friends growing
up okay [ __ ]
like snakebite missiles like this stupid
[ __ ] like hell it knows how to do it to
you later
no ma predator did losers at the sandbox
you guys are friends you [ __ ] losers
ha dude all the dumb things you did as a
kid good for you Joe staying out of that
conversation wait wait whoa hey why
there he's in Florida
no Oklahoma wait so there was was it a
rattlesnake um so they're just saying is
a five-foot five inch snake what was it
doing in the air it was coiled on the
porch light and it pounds his face when
he opened the screen door to you I know
but the funny part about that [ __ ] is
there's nobody there right he goes take
me to the hospital blow
I thought you if he was visiting his
friend's house so he was walking into
that house he was going into his own
house that he goes Hospital are you okay
[Applause]
cop comes by what happened
is the burner that never gets on why the
[ __ ] is a snake wrapped and coiled on a
[ __ ] lights it is probably on and it
was warm oh no cause like I don't I
don't know I'm just thinking snakes in
America don't like wrap around in trees
and [ __ ] like the Amazon I just think
they're always on the ground somewhere
we had one in where were we what was
that [ __ ] city we were at for our
retreat the rattlesnake
Oh something that weird please San Diego
no I saw what the J oh no or something
yeah something like that yeah it came
into our house was her [ __ ]
rattlesnake and it was coiled up Joshua
Tree no sweet hi-yah no Callisto Jamaica
it's like San Diego's here and then like
an hour
inland yeah and then Beach juniper
juniper it sounds close it was near
where PE Choi was gonna sleep and he
like walked up the stairs right next to
it and he didn't get bit and then he
wasn't that big man no and then he
looked down and then he was like oh [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] rattlesnake look what
if he stepped on that [ __ ]
no more Polly dude cuz he's cool
especially at that time cuz he had his
thyroid [ __ ] happening yeah he's great
that's crazy I thought it was the same
one where you guys got the truck stuck
in the lake Mel how's it different
you guys wait a minute back it up
Tiffany I was warning his ass not to so
then it's like what this man runs into
the house and he's like take me like but
he just he didn't know if it was gonna
be a venomous snake so then there's a
party to start I'm not really so what
happened was that the the wife like so
the woman that lived in that home she
started screaming
along with no
other guys they got bid as well although
they were screaming didn't get bit so
then because they were screaming so much
they attracted a neighbor who came over
with a hammer to pound the snake to
death yeah but what about the guy no one
took him to the hospital he went saw so
they kept the boundedness snake - can
you imagine all the holes on their wall
with hammers he's saying that there were
no stitches but that he was cleaned up
good and that they put him on
antibiotics and the snake was not
venomous
crush him somewhere but it's still
smooth I will burn that whole house down
just to get that snake out so now the
homeowners saying that he's gonna cover
his yard with sulfuric acid cuz it
snakes don't like that he said I hear
they don't like that wait is it toxic
for humans though I don't know I don't
even know what sulphuric acid is yeah
and I [ __ ] people [ __ ] can we
play it out again who who comes after
him and acid gardener guy comes blacks
woodenly I mean the mailman hey guys
they had to kill this thing because they
need to speak to see if it's venomous or
yeah yeah and snakes aren't animals
either so it doesn't matter
[ __ ] them even in the Bible they're evil
dude if I eat them is it okay
Oh cuz everything in the Bible is truth
exactly dude that's right they say there
were giants in the Bible your life
that's no thanks or cuddle with me it
was using your warmth
pixal wasn't cuddling with cuddly that
is not cuddly she would tell you is she
I slept with her one night and she did
you fed her if you didn't feed her she
would have [ __ ] killed you you slept
with a snake yeah did you ever see that
one viral video remember the one
watching there was like the circus
performer he's like this skinny ass dude
he goes and like with the snake and he
has like a Python wrapped around him it
was just wrapped around his neck and he
just kept crawling about his neck and
then he was just
brought you were watching Beth together
and everyone in the audience is looking
at him and his arm started coming up
don't even help them know cuz she's
cuddling dude that's why it's gotta
leave do remember Gina snake the red
tail boa the six foot long I never
visited destiny um well anyway she had
the snake and then Casey and I ended up
fostering her and we had her for a
minute and so we would play with her in
the bed all the time like while I was
tells are just instant use and stuff and
then she would like she liked coiling up
in her and I what is it pillow cake and
then one time we just fall asleep with
her and the reptiles have no motions
they're just [ __ ] reactionary no
body's warm that's still cuddly if you
were cold as hell she would not want to
be with you
[Laughter]
Casey though this bar in Ohio was
serving this new cocktail cocktail yes
cocktail and this cocktail was garnished
with a tampon yeah tampons have like a
Bloody Mary
a bloody he's not nice because the
tampons gonna suck the drink out so this
drink or as cocktails they've named it
can't even I mean even can't literally
that's the name of it even cat litter it
can't literally and can't even that's
what I thought but that's why I said
campers I like that I can't even
I even I can't Leroy yeah
so it's a berry margarita where's the
temple and come into this it's garnished
with the Tampa should have been Bloody
Mary yeah but you have the drink it's so
fast oh that's why I mean yeah it does
suck it but I can expand on oh that's
weird
these are berries that's what it looks
like minstrel wood it's pretty cool it's
not though because there's no like they
should have named it something you know
what I mean like even can't literally
and then it has a tampon and it's a
berry drink what's happening that even
can't literally it's like female
vernacular like you know what yeah
you're like I I can't even no even can't
literally yeah it's just all backwards
like I literally can't even but that's
not female vocabulary it is though yeah
so they're saying that if you buy this
cocktail one dollar will go towards um
towards funding this women's shelter in
their area tight and so the whole point
of this drink is to bring awareness that
women have periods cuz I know we all
know it's not a [ __ ] miss no it's
because women have periods okay period
is because a lot of homeless ladies do
where they gonna get their hygienic they
don't yeah that's the biggest thing
socks and and those type of they don't
put the [ __ ] tampons in the drink
yeah give it to them [ __ ] women what
a waste they're saying that you don't
want the tampon in your drink you could
say he'd donate that to the woman who
the [ __ ] is like now put the gym can I
get two tampons hold yourself on just
like excuse me where the [ __ ] is my
tampon yeah the [ __ ] get this drink back
I can't gets agree on this I know maybe
it's like the umbrella and the drink
even can't literally because I thought I
thought the reason why they put the
tampon is was that you stuck it in and
then you have to drink it before it
absorbs so you're beating the Tampa or
you just use it to absorb and then you
squeeze it out or like they have
something in the tampon and you have to
squeeze out that ingredient oh that's
pretty good too that's cool so this
whole point of this drink it's not meant
to shock or disgust people it was to get
them talking about women's health and
then so that's obviously what's
happening now dude do you know how much
those things can [ __ ] absorb with the
pad yeah I showed you tonight yeah but
so I used to carry a bunch of pads in my
backpack for a minute before she carries
on back liar I knew you put I [ __ ]
knew you had a
yeah okay Gio I get it I have a [ __ ] I
really do though but when we were going
around either way I took it out the
backpack but I put it in my one of my
pants pockets and then when we washed it
it [ __ ] expanded like a [ __ ]
dude it was like a solid five pounds oh
[ __ ] she takes in a lot of [ __ ] we did
the experiment here we had a pad and we
try to do like a commercial you know
they would go along like if I if I had
it and I slap the [ __ ] out of somebody
with it they would knock out yeah that's
how much weight it carries didn't do
that with a tampon though it opened up
like a [ __ ] butterfly oh I thought it
was a pad that sounds we put it in
remember I was like keep the string in
and yeah and then we take out the
plastic applicator it's like magic yep
so they got a lot of attention online
curly because that's so cool so the bar
patrons they were like I don't know why
people are upset like it's not offensive
to me I mean I guess I can I kind of can
see why people would get offended but it
doesn't ruin my day people are offended
who got offended mean hello anything
gets to be offended I think it's weird
you know from now on I wanna they were
offended because they're saying that a
mocks female vernacular with the drink
name and it degrades the female bodily
function who's the [ __ ] man that got
offended I know the guy they got mad
yeah who's the guy who's the guy I want
to see I want to see this guy I think a
little bit on behalf of women a little
bit of evil to do a lot of good is a
good thing and I should mention too that
man there was a woman who created this
car yeah so I can't even so who is the
guy that got offended I know right every
time someone gets offended we should
like get their name their [ __ ]
everything and in their comment and then
see what they said I think I think
that's what should happen yeah just just
this so I'm a little [ __ ] no because I
think when people go oh the internet got
offended or whatever it's usually not
99% of people it's like 1% of idiot that
has a voice yeah there's always that
[ __ ] [ __ ] no matter what and I can't
even
next story our last story this woman was
thrown off a flight in New Zealand makes
sense
she brought our Kiwis after their she
refused to pay attention to the the
safety instructions no I never pay
attention I've been on so many flight
rails
I always pay attention where are you
you're already out you're sweet no I pay
attention swear so what do you do in mid
of a plane crashing what are you
supposed to do you grab a question from
underneath the chair you put it on you
go if that doesn't work you suck on your
dead in the line yeah you get in the
line where they're supposed to be an
inflatable slide and you sit there why
do you watch the videos all the time
just to refresh my memory keep some [ __ ]
you forgot about the air man falls down
you put yours on first and then you put
on the one on the kid and then your wife
yes no your your wife you take it and
you breathe would you because you take
your wife did you do that in an
instructional video I would love that
[ __ ] people would take that so seriously
and then their accident I want to get
offended I know but then the guy they
can do for the guy as well to to play
blow signs do you do you remember that
troll who made the [ __ ] airplane
airplane safety thing but it's like aw
like scared disaster we like the daigon
[ __ ] fires and blood
yeah and they put it in wasn't that in
Fight Club was in the movie Fight Club
and I thought we did a JK news article
like click yeah I don't know it was
years ago people memories get distorted
so anyway this woman here so she was
with a man like she was accompanied by a
man and they were both they both was
they were looking at their phones when
the instructional of the safety video
started playing and because of the fact
that they were in the exit row that's
why the flight flight attendant was very
patient and asked them like can you
please watch what's happening because
this is the exit row and then that's
when the woman put her fingers in her
ears oh I would kick her out just for
being a [ __ ] yeah that's probably what
happened
anything up taking the gate I mean the
plane back to the gate oh [ __ ] it went
bad
yes oh no they weren't in the air yet
you know it's like what you're still
taxi yeah yeah yeah I didn't even know
that they like moved yeah so he left the
gate when that happened and so this is
good of doing the flight for 25 minutes
they'll be dope if the whole entire like
everyone was just like just shaming the
[ __ ] out of ya shame ding ding ding ding
they're saying that police are waiting
at the gate but I don't know what
happened to her once she did they shave
her head and they walk her naked down
the [ __ ] oh you know you know at the
end of the day it's like for her safety
right I hate people that are [ __ ] so
stubborn when it's for your safety yeah
so like when they come up to you and
tell you it's not even that they're
power tripping it's like everyone should
know this [ __ ] especially if you're in
the exit row cuz you're [ __ ] you're
expected to open that [ __ ] for other
people you can't freak out in that
moment and that [ __ ] is like shut up
don't tell me what that dough
she started reading a book she was just
like and so as she was getting kicked
off the flight that's when like she
pulled out her phone again and she was
loudly trying to book another flight on
this budget airline I would ban her ass
what do you mean loudly highway well how
is she doing it loud it's on her phone
no I guess she's like
then I guess I'm gonna look at Jeff oh
she's being obnoxious oh oh so you gonna
disrespect me guess I gotta go to the
budget yeah this is Air New Zealand will
forget you I'm going to Ryan my boy
yeah and then the other airline is
called Jetstar you only treat people
bike you okay she should be exactly what
I would do would treat me like this you
know what I bet you I find out where you
live better watch out well my cousin day
to kick yo ass when it comes to flying
and all that [ __ ] I don't think the
customers ever right good company comes
first
yeah all those random videos though
about those like Asian passengers and
they're all like humbly and still you
don't understand stuff in the media and
like ripped off the plane getting beaten
sup DC she should have been dr. Daoud
yeah you should have been doctored dad
good to me you kill me [ __ ] doctor
down man
that's the og though I love that video
not what happened to him but the ripple
effect that it had yeah and how dramatic
he was being hanging on that curtain
took cumin to cue me hilarious time has
passed this money now
[Music]